ok ok herzlich willkommen anderen
demonstrieren sie universität ich freue
mich sehr dass sie alle hier in münchen
ganz besondere freude
auch die mich auch ein bisschen stolz
und diese heute und morgen hier nur
antworten geben aus verschiedenen
perspektiven zunächst ausführlich von
der hochschule der künste in münchen an
aktien günstig und südwesten kommt der
universität in bamberg deutlich
das ist rechtzeitig geschafft hat dann
hat man auch schon sagen wegen morgen
vor ist so förster peter anders von der
universität in bath gestoßen
nach einem recht spitz oder in den mund
und westerwald im zimmer aus der schweiz
der begriff der digitalität ist seit
einiger zeit in aller munde und jetzt
besondere die kultur
geisteswissenschaftler rahmen für sich
entdecken in dem prozess entschieden und
mit 100 derzeit geradezu inflationär
verwendet und lehrern lernszenarien
zwischen mitnehmen der irgendwas in
digitalen medien passiert und ich habe
das gefühl die sozialen netzwerke im
winter sein ist also hashtag in die
qualität ihrer ein neues kriterium
geworden zu sein
wenn man jetzt aber den aktuellen des
großen erfolg scheint nach außen kehren
musste darauf zu bestehen was den
tatsachen zu verstehen ist weniger
steilen knüpft in seinem buch von 2000
das recht von einem kultur digitalität
damit fischer 50 auch unsere tage es ist
in sieben letztendlich das phänomen
digitalität näher zu bestimmen und dazu
den blick auf kulturelle aber auch
philosophische soziologische und nicht
zuletzt pädagogische und didaktische das
leben sie in einer digitalisierten welt
zu leben und tragen möchte ich folgende
fragen zu stellen
in zweimal über ergebnis dieser domäne
digitalisierung digitalisieren stehen
wir sagen uns wie sich lehr und
lernprozesse im kontext und
digitalisierung verändern welche
herausforderungen chance probleme sich
aus an digitalität für die zukunft der
gesellschaft unserem präsidenten
eingeben und letztendlich wie sich eine
kultur der digitalität beziehen
gestalten leicht zu merken ist gekommen
alle zuschauer ebenso zum besten geben
sie seien ein ganz neues programm und
ist auch schon sagen wir versuchen es
umzusetzen das heißt alles was jetzt
hier ist immer gleich ein bisschen zeit
sie haben sich jetzt auch klein auf
youtube zu strecken
eine 27 exkursionen gibt verfolgen
können wenn sie kann natürlich alles
hier seriös diskutieren
ich würde etwas ganz kurz sagen so
anders dieser tage als einem jahr
gemacht die messe didacta entchen
stellen wir hatten eine wiederwahl
gemacht hat in diesen tagen ist ganz
klar die ameisen zu behaupten die
qualität und können
vitalität wirklich sinnvollen im gesicht
eines wissen wir hatten damals sehr sehr
kritische stimmen gehört
das können wir noch ein bisschen positiv
ja wir haben gerade kleine auf ein
bisschen mehr mit zu gestalten daraus
ist ein
dieser tage entstanden und ich wollte
nicht dass es klappt dass wir sie
gemeinsam organisieren können und
informationen zum technischen zeit
parodien die vorteile wer über sein
wissen und können eine diskussion
bereits auf diesen sprüchen kanadas
amtierenden sind in china konnten sie
geben zu erkennen gerät kann man das
schafft integration können sie also
wirklich schon ein gegen sich dann
glaube ich ganz sicher sonst auf dem
programm und man scheint absolut auf dem
campus vorne bei der registrierung an
die kurzwahl sein
dieser wurde die entscheidung ist
programm
dann können sie natürlich mit ist und
hier nicht an twitter unter dem hashtag
digitalität und zwar signalisieren dass
man sich hier entstehen weiter und ist
seit 11 45 bis 12 35 jähriger in diesem
raum eine plenumsdiskussion abstand zu
den themen der tagung sind alle da immer
interessant aber schon haben sie
diese fragen auch schon von einzureichen
über diese zeit hat er bekanntlich
diskussion ergebnissen klar ist jetzt
schon fragen einreichen und schauen uns
über das kann man hier auch per sprache
bringen als sie können direkt mit dass
diesmal hatte die uns auch nicht zu
dieser sagen einige der freunde meine
von dieser materialien zeigt auch einige
posten darauf hinweisen folgen ein
mitarbeiter fand ich so nicht sagen
die haben eine neue technologie hat mit
ihrem fahrzeug vorstände die auch die
kita bremen beträgt und mein mitarbeiter
sich eher in einem post ihr biograf in
einzelnen unternehmen selbst und waltz
gibt der nähe
das sind sie alles
vorher konnte im bau es materialien
hinein dann können die fragen wie kommt
er zu sein
oder weil es ist ein fehler ist jetzt
erfolgt sehr gut aber sie könnte ich
diese dieses netzwerk gelenkt harmlosen
diese sind zudem
ja man zuletzt wollen wir jetzt andere
war eines von zwei nämlich der lehre
dieses jahr angestiegen sind und sehr
verwandt werden die sozialkassen können
wir legen jetzt hier sehr günstig
dies könnte den wänden rechten zwischen
der getränkeausgabe mit kinderspielplatz
tisch gehen wir ja sehr gerne noch ein
ist rentieren würde die blasen zu lesen
und vielleicht ein bier trinken also es
ist für alle offen jeder verwenden
soweit sie noch da sind auf die kommt es
jetzt auch noch nehmendes in den usa auf
ich bin halt einiges zu bieten
es ist das was dann tatsächlich losgehen
mit weniger steilen also nur kurz geduld
und dann
vielen dank für die freundliche
einladung wenn ich mich bei einem jahr
gefreut habe danke liebe hinführung
damit ein wichtiges ließen ein genialer
eintrag zu schreiben
überlassen sie das licht zu können ich
muss gleich darauf schließen dass ich
wie jeder aufgefrischt oder ökologisch
sozusagen eine fachkraft finden
ich bin sozial und kulturwissenschaftler
ohne briefwahl ja gesagt hat an einer
kunsthochschule nehme ich meine
bemerkungen hier was die eines fremden
aber ich hoffe dass es genauso sein
aus der perspektive auch die eine
anregungen bringen kann ich möchte über
drei themenbereichen sprechen würde für
sich gesehen eigenen vortrag von ihnen
besprechen wenn ich überall sehr knapp
mich verhalten aber mit diesem zusammen
dieser themenbereich wichtigen und ich
hoffe und sagen denn das große mehrere
die breite entschädigt für die
skizzenhafte kainz er ausführen
ich werde erst versuchen die bei dem
begriffe digitalisierungen digitalität
und einander abzugrenzen
danach etwas durch die parität aber gut
die kultur der digitalität sagen und
danach mich auf ganz dünnes eis begeben
und versuchen regen zu kämpfen
aus dieser perspektive auf die
digitalität übung aufzudrängen
zunächst einmal was ist der begriff aus
ist digitalisierung oder was verstehe
ich unter kritisieren die interessieren
mich die einen prozess der überführung
und analogen situation in einem lied
alle dinge die bisher die kinder
analogen medien organisiert wurden
werden am ende des prozesses mit hilfe
digitaler medien organisiert
das ist ein recht im mordprozess
da geht es natürlich einerseits um hard
und software
es kann aber es geht auch um in monza
erfahrungen und erlebnisse und her es
geht und nutzungsgewohnheiten
sowas erwartungen es geht um inhalte und
die form ihrer aufbereitung all diese
dinge werden transformiert von einer
sammlung form in eine andere im prozess
der digitalisierung
es ist also der umfassende konformation
von bewegungs und gemüse und handlungs
prozessen in der gesellschaft historisch
gesehen ist es nicht das erste mal dass
eine solche umfassende veränderungen
dieser ordnung dieser wahrnehmung seiner
minister wandlungsprozesse stattfindet
der sonst so sagen geschichtlich
vorgenommen der begriff wäre der er alle
juden
auch dies war und ist nach wie vor weil
somit ist es im prozess der nie ganz
abgeschlossen ist geht es nicht nur um
eine individuelle fertigkeiten zu sagen
es eher begrenzt
der gehalt des lesens und schreibens
sondern es ist ein prozess mit einem
ganzen in sozialen umfeld mit schulen de
vanna der in münchen unter theken
verladung auszeichnungen förderungen
setze auf die notwendig sind damit sich
diese fähigkeit des lesens und
schreibens an sinnvollen erfolgen kann
man kann man digitalisierung zu sagen
durchaus analoge setzen und einen
ähnlichen ähnlich verstehen wie im alten
weg ist
entsprechend ist die mentalitäten daraus
entstehen und der prozess der
digitalisierung einem gewissen umfang
eine gewisse tiefe reißt die vitalität
wie es eine spezifische möglichkeitsform
materiellen kulturelle bedingungen die
nach gewissen muster strukturiert ist
und die gewissenlos und gewisse waren
neben unsere sichtweisen ermöglicht oder
bevorzugt könnte man sagen und damit
anderen finalisten der im berichtsjahr
digitalität der erschwinglichkeit
die kultur von der englischen print
carter ist
auch die jetzt dort oder ums der
alphabetisierung einem gewissen grad
eine gewisse tiefe erreicht hat so dass
die darin enthaltenen möglichkeiten
begonnen die wahrnehmung und das handeln
der menschen zu prägen
so entstand sollte es eine neue
kollektive sensibilität aber regeln
verpflichtungen erwartungen situationen
die vielleicht class der analyse der
kultur der schlechtigkeit lisa d max
weber in seinen studien bürokratie die
auf rationale herrschaft bezeichnet dass
eine organisationsform in einer meta
tags oder auf der couch aus der
schriftlichkeit und jeder vormund
schlechte festgehalten werden
die auch ziele und eine ganze
organisation sekunden andere
organisationsform entstanden daraus mit
dem spezifischen set von möglichkeiten
und was das immer auch als im
spezifischen von unmöglichkeit die
qualität und schriftlichkeit also zwei
unterschiedliche formen der wahrnehmung
und erholungsmöglichkeiten und da es
entwickelt sich sehr unterschiedliche
erfahrungen und welche bildung und
plakativen gegenüber so
gegenüberzustellen lassen sich mit uns
regieren will zwei medienland jeweils
auf der höhe ihrer zeit darstellen wie
der mensch in der natürlichen umwelt
steht auf der linken seite haben sie
ernst haeckels bericht im stammbaum des
menschen
1874 auf der rechten seite haben sie
eine illustration zu einem
wissenschaftlichen kongress zum 0 1 von
und 2017 links die das wesentliche
ganz oben steht am ende sind die ihr
vermögen und
dazwischen ist eine stabile irakische
ordnung eine lineare entwicklung nach
oben in der jedes der einige keinen
eindeutigen glaubhaft die teile sind im
sich stabil und diese darstellung
der baum lässt sich subjektiv das von
außen oder in spezifischen blickwinkel
darstellen rechts ist sofern der neue
ein verändertes bildung des menschen der
es steht es hier immer noch im
mittelpunkt aber dieser mittelpunkt ist
einer der erkenntnis interesse
diese zeichnung unfertigen kommen das
ist keine behauptung dass er menschen in
ihren durch spitze steht könnte genau
gleiche zeichen machen
die fliege ins zentrum stellen in einer
weise niemand in der unterzeichnung der
unterzeichnung die arminen an die spitze
stellen
der mensch ist vielfältig offen
verhindern er ist einflüssen von außen
2008 über nicht mir auch technologisch
oder kultureller art der mensch hier ist
nicht mehr einheit sondern eines mit
lotus komposit das ist was dieser
begriff des orions meinen also hier mehr
zwei gaumen zum unterschiedliche
hinterherlaufen was es bedeutet zu sagen
ein mensch zu sein wie der mensch
konzipiert ist und diese stehen jeweils
repräsentativen verschiedene zusätzliche
wahrnehmungsweisen wie sie die welt
sehen
soviel zum unterschied von
digitalisierung die
lassen sie mich jetzt zur kultur der
digitalität kommen was sozusagen diese
mit dieser struktur der wahrnehmung des
konsens bedeutet wir erfahren
dieser moment ist übergang ist dieser
moment der sozusagen wolfener
schriftkultur immer mehr kultur der
digitalität übergehen gleichzeitigen als
moment der krise anders moment der neu
und lassen sie mich zuerst über die
krise sprechen um zu verstehen warum
diese krise unerträglich ist und warum
welche motive aus
das müssen wir dann nur mit namen sonst
haben wir zum richtigen gebrauch unserer
erklärung zum scheitern verurteilt
entsprechend sollte unsere
aufmerksamkeit darauf gerichtet sein
die neue hoffnung da musst du gestalten
und das heißt auf diese gestaltung nicht
anderen zu überlassen sondern mit
unseren eigenen gesehen eigenen werten
eigenen vor
einzugreifen wenn wir die neuordnung
kommen dann überlassen
dann heißt es im moment dass die freude
man ein markt orientierten akteuren
überlaufen
wenn der ganze baum in der vorstellung
davon haben wie diese facebook
dies ist diese neue möglichkeit dar um
ausgestaltet werden soll
als wir das vielleicht haben woher kommt
um diese krise der bestehenden mitteln
installationen und wahrnehmungsmuster um
es auf einen begriff zu reduzieren
komplexität in den letzten 50 jahren
diese komplexität auf allen gebieten
rasant gestiegen und sich da immer noch
nach die bestehenden kulturellen
verfahren und sozialen institutionen
sind immer weniger in der lage mit
dieser komplexität umzugehen
die steigerung der komplexität kommt
daher dass in fast allen prozessen heute
mehr möhringen
ziehen sie artikulieren eine größere
positionen und ihre interaktionen und
die damals bestehenden kollektiven mit
leeren händen verändern sich schnell
herum mehr akteuren mehr positionen mehr
die note liegt es gibt auch eine
qualitative eine qualitative oder den
prozessen orientieren der steigung und
der kulturellen vieler kulturellen
dimensionen unserer gesellschaft und
kultur verstehe ich ganz einfach
das warum ausgeteilte bedeutung
bezeichnen kann
sie geht es ja nichts getan einmal in
größeren oder kleineren gruppen
aber sie beantwortet und dessen ist die
frage was ist richtig was ist toll was
ist schön
es ist hässlich grundsätzlich wieso wir
lieben
der konsens und sagen das geländer und
bedeutung dass die verständigen und
worten auf diese fragen ist näher und es
gibt immer akteure dass sich ein konsens
in frage stellen nicht insofern ist air
berlin
menschen ändern verlangsamung und wir
sind vielleicht letzten zeit besonders
schnell in bewegung ist weil viele
aufhören und sagen wir dem grundsatz dem
es vielleicht aufgewachsen sind nicht
mehr zufrieden
woher kommen diese vielen akteure mit
ihren höchst unterschiedlichen
positionen denn die war sind wir nicht
einfach plötzlich erschienen das noma
historischer prozess und die größe
dieses prozesses leute daran dass hat
unumkehrbar ist der erste große strafen
der zu dieser komplettierung führt hat
ist auf das muss aus allgemeinen seit
den 60er jahren als wissensökonomie
bezeichnet das wort versteht man die
veränderung der wirtschaft welche von
standardisierter produktion der club dem
klassischen fließt an sich sei der
klassischen industrie arbeiten unsere
flexiblen dienstleister durch das auch
die trainerfunktion es geht mir nicht um
die materialisierung zusammen -
leistungs gehorchend auch in materieller
produktionen die spezialisiert ist
diesem zusammenhang zitiert werden wird
und das stellt unsere neue
herausforderung und die menschen alles
unseren arbeiten deswegen in diesem
veränderten umfeld sondern agieren
sollen und wir müssen einerseits
kommunikation spielt eine größere rolle
immer mehr menschen lernen und werden
dazu angehalten selbst zu kommunizieren
in der öffentlichkeit zu sprechen eine
eigene meinung zu generieren und diese
auch gut zu tun
das zweite fundamentale ist eine
zunehmende wichtigkeit von koordination
kraft dass teamarbeit sowohl in den
dienst
im inneren sind aber auch zwischen
diesen teams firmenübergreifend das
projekt lieber greifen mit immer
notwendiger das heißt die arbeit selbst
mit im median in größeren einheiten er
nicht was er sich vorerst auf eine
größere einheit aber die gestaltung
dieser einheiten die induktive
die nationen nach veränderung der formen
der zusammenarbeit ist etwas was der
krieg arbeitet sage von der person ihrer
wahl stehen nicht aber aus mehr zu
nehmen sonst zusammengekommen und
menschen hermachen und da aus bei denen
auch die das umfeld sich immer stärker
verändert wird immer mehr x mal explizit
der medizin der gewissen
problemlösungskompetenz er war träger
der wiesmann stellt ihr das liebste zum
stimme zu hören brauchte um wieder
anfängt folgten angehalten selbst im
teams lösungen wird sich dauernd
veränderte problemstellungen zu hören
dass immer mehr menschen erleben sich
werden angehalten werden ausgebildete
zum von der grundschule sich selber als
personen mit einem eigenen listen
meinung zu verstehen und der komplette
ist diese auch meine kleineren und
größeren gruppen zu vertreten
das heißt hier im osten weil
massenhafter weise sozusagen das
sprechen und die formulierung von
differenz ein gebiet parallelnutzung aus
anderen motivationen warum ebenfalls als
sechziger jahren eine enorme soziale
polarisierung statt
nehren verschiedene erfahrungen
lebensweisen können tituliert werden
heute in der öffentlichkeit und
verlangen auch anerkennung was natürlich
dazu führt dass die unterschiedlichsten
positionen stärker miteinander sozusagen
abgeglichen werden müssen denken sie nur
an die rasant gestiegene zahl von
konsultationen die wir heute als
familien bezeichnet
das ist sehr sehr viel vielfältiger und
vor 30 40 jahren kam nach wehnen
dieser prozess nicht ohne erwidert
stattfinden und stärke damit die
reaktionen auslöst und keiner weise
sozusagen eine ungleichheiten aufgibt
ist es trotzdem ein prozess der eine
eindeutige richtung hin zu einer
sozialen polarisierung hat in
deutschland mittlerweile vor zwei jahren
die linie wieder eingeführt und das ist
sozusagen konservativen konzern
das zeigt doch dass diese prozesse sehr
einfachen grund der gesellschaft damit
natürlich die die notwendigkeit der auch
anders ist
was muss dann heute die richtige
ernährung in einer vielzahl von gebieten
stattfindet und damit den kommunikativen
und text
610 euro entstanden er trinke sonst sei
das haben richter der in den letzten
jahrzehnten liegt die komplette
gesteigert haben ist einerseits und die
globalisierung immer mehr
unterschiedliche kulturelle erfahrungen
miteinander in kontakt bringt
andererseits aber die kolonialisierung
die es nicht mehr einfach endlich dieser
unterschiedlichen erfahrungen irakischen
konnten wir können heute nicht mehr von
der ersten version bringt mehr
entsprechen und die rolle der dritten
welt ist die entwicklung der ersten
wende schnell nachzuvollziehen und haft
diese hauptversammlung ist das her
avisieren verschiedene kulturelle
erfahrungen bis heute hochgradig
problematisch geworden
entsprechend geht es auch bei der
einwanderung nicht einfach oben
nominierung sondern um eine produktive
übrigens was ist natürlich einfach
dieser prozess fordert stark gegen
letzte heraus als werden
immerhin aber ist der einzige weg in
produktiven diesen strukturellen
veränderungen umzugehen
entsprechend diskutieren wir heute auch
über dinge ähnlich wie die familien die
noch vor 30 jahren sinken da gewesen
werden etwa die frage jährigen
aufklärung generell positiv wir werden
und kolonialismus
mit strukturierten auto oder fahrer nie
gehört nicht in diese regionen zu
erobern
das sind alles momenten die jede soziale
musste er aber dieses an solche
wanderungen mit einigen die norm verein
danken dass jetzt nur dass beliebige
beispiel beispiel was heißt es richtig
zu wenn er ist sehr sehr sehr viel
komplexer geworden und mit sehr viel
aufwändiger diskutiert
30 jahren also ihre enorme veränderung
des sozialen basis aber auch der artikel
ihren positionen
die medien verhandeln
es ist richtig was ist falsch wie sollen
wir leben erlösen soll
zusammengeschlagen
diese enorme vielen vervielfältigungen
an jetzt ein zeichen dieser aber vieles
ist gar nicht mehr richtig sich als
trägerinnen sprecher unterstrich
das soll als ersatz haben auf dieser
ebene schon fan treffen wollen
diese vervielfältigung überfordert die
bestehenden kulturellen ordnungssysteme
er ist immer darauf aus gehen bringe ich
den warmen nach bestimmten kriterien zu
einem informations linie zu bringen ist
das geht weit hinter das internet zurück
was also tun mit dem internet entstanden
nächsten das geht eigentlich die kritik
der repräsentation oder inklusion gibt
es bereits seit den noch nicht richtig
verharrt auf den 1970 er jahren kannte
dem zeitpunkt als auch als dieser
realisierung 1 s min er den bestehenden
institutionen eben nicht nur ein
beispiel ist etwa die aktionen des
öfteren korrektiven charakter börse hier
sehen ist 1989 vor seinem internet zeit
und massiv thematisieren ist weniger
haben
diese - mit schlecht deswegen kaufte er
kunst historisches kurs vielleicht ganz
kritischer diskurs zum auswahlverfahren
die einem museum in ebenen metropolitan
museum unternehmen als andere diskussion
von den auswirkungen für tiere
diskussionen machen würde und das
problem mit uns heute es nicht einfach
das nicht genug den großen museen hängen
das ist auch ein problem aber das geht
heute noch viel gemeinsam
wenn ich jetzt die frage wessen
kategorien behauptet angewendet werden
sollen
alles sollte auswahl zu treffen wer ist
überhaupt das in der repräsentation
würdige minderheiten in deutschland in
der repräsentation city gegründet zu
haben
anerkannt und damit notwendigen in der
weise
dass auch die kunst der gegenwart
kurzgeschichte darstellen will der muss
dort eingeschlossen die krieges
etablierten ordnungssystem erließ das es
dass es nicht mehr gelingen dass eine
spezifische sozialkunde und das war's am
mann ist das bürgertum nach dem 19
jahrhundert kommen
das ist eine rose gelingt ihren
kategorien für normale
selbstverständlich und natürlich zu
erklären schon die einfache frage wie
viele geschlechter es gibt es heute all
seinen phasen werden wird wahr geworden
entsprechend eben sind solche fragen
werden im zuge seiner präsentation wie
in einem museum sehr sehr viel komplexer
geworden
die guerilla bei uns gemacht haben die
aber für diesen den anfangsjahren des
momentes stehen
das eine fundamentale kritik an die
bestehenden kulturellen ordnungssysteme
seit 1970 er jahren auch als reaktion
auf dieser unzufriedenheit entstehenden
monika zions infrastrukturen die
signalisierung artikulieren
die bestehenden kanäle gehirn zu
artikulieren ist das ist ein interesse
an die öffentlichkeit von uns und
unseren massenmedial öffentlichkeiten
waren so wäre das problematisch wird er
fehlen linke der kombination
erfahrungswerten
und dann brauche ich heute unter dich
vor das intresse ausgebaut hatte
medien an zeitungen radio und tv
stationen aber alternativen freunde die
enormen richtigen die herausbildung
einer umgangssprache einer sprache die
uns diese qualität diese vielfalt keine
ausbildung von centaurus universitäten
aus diesem speziellen
austreten konnten ihnen jeden allgemeine
verwunderung aber das große problem
dieser umsätze war ihre skalierung dass
es wenigen war die schnell rauskommen
und prozent dass sie tun mit der
ökonomie das an der etablierten
nachmelden
es ist wenn er einfach einen text zu
schreiben aber sehr sehr schwierige zeit
haben nutzen zu vertreiben
dieselben kritischen überlegungen
alternative kommunikationsmedien zu
schaffen schlossen auch natürlich nicht
nur noch gibt es andere entwicklung
strecke aber verschlossen auch melden
die entwicklung des internets 1 auch
hier war die idee sozusagen über die
veränderung der kommunikationsmuster auf
erinnert das an gesellschaftliche
realitäten zu schaffen und verarmung ein
regeltest element auch das internet auch
der allerdings nicht lange
das kann hier das problem zu verbinden
und eine kritische masse zu erreichen
dieses video wird
was auch in dieser medien experimente
sagt der 19 14 versuchen geblieben
eine struktur zu schaffen mit der mehr
informationen immer größere diversität
zu verbreiten und auch in der einen oder
anderen form neue rollen einzuüben
die strikte trennung von sendern und
empfängern auszugeben
der charme des klassischen
bürgerfernsehen noch mit unserem
technischen klassische rot chaos
situation ist eben gerade dass es nicht
so wie es sind die medien machen sondern
es heute sind die das team programm
gestalten für ihre eigene kunden
community und dem großen gewisses
denkens und damit sondern gleichzeitig
verhindert und empfänger ihres eigenen
programms in dem seit den 2000er jahren
können sie fünf jahre aktien oder 10
jahre dazu stellt zumindest kann man
nicht so
einziges jahr nehmen aber sagen wir mal
seit 2000 ungefähr beginnt diese
infrastruktur diese attraktive medien in
verstopfung natürlich vor allem das
internet
das haben wir zunehmend dominant zu
werden und es beginnt die in ihrer
legitimation bereits geschwächten
zusammen kulturellen institutionen
eigene an den armen zu trennen und jetzt
sozusagen nicht mehr nur endlich möglich
nicht mehr nur möglich sagen mit dem
verkauf von metropolitan visier um art
zu stehen sondern es ist möglich eine
andere zusammen
rosa und scala der anderen worden
zuschauer und wieder andere unternehmen
ist und warum wird die dominant grund
nächster ist besser heißt es nicht
sozusagen kulturellen näher am leben als
wir uns vielleicht wünschen sondern sie
ist eben besser geeignet die rasch
wachsende komplexität zu worden
das heißt ganz einfach das silikon in
der konkurrenz um die aufmerksamkeit und
das vertrauen der nutzer gewinnen
gegenüber diesen institutionen die schon
herumgekommen zusagen in ihrer
legitimierte nation infrage gestellt
waren zivilen unseren auch und mehrwert
an der montagsdemo ist kennen das sicher
ich würde mich beispielsweise persönlich
als uncool
stauber kinder von google bezeichnet
ich habe eine 67 mehrwert bieten und
auch um dieses besser er ist es den
wolken erlaubt mehr so zu haben vielmehr
wunderer ordnungssysteme nicht erlauben
zu tun und damit sozusagen beginnend
auch eine aufmerksamkeit eine
sensibilität aufzubauen falls die
ausbauen und sagen die oder auf spanien
komme aus der paul es aber nicht geben
und da es entstehen sie sehen ein sich
selbst verstärkender prozess eher zu
nehmen und an geschwindigkeit gewinnt
denn wenn es möglich ist mit großen
informationsmengen produktiver umzugehen
dann kann nach immer mehr produziert
werden dann kann sich sozusagen für
kulturelle verloren sind junge reiter
aus denen und wir haben auch
fundamentale diskussionen zwischen
vegetarier und veganer nämlich leistung
das heißt aber auch dass es immer
spielen da wäre die etablierenden
vorkommen mit gewalt und sie vor allem
gemeinsamen
zurück und scheinen entsprechen die man
aus dieser veränderten bedingungen der
arbeit aus kontinuität
doch damit wird es schon dominant
geworden ist kommentiert lassen sich
langsam andere nutzt diesen worten
strukturiert ist identifizieren
93 grundmuster lassen sind meiner
meinung auch der 1
ich gehe davon aus dass mit der zeit
noch anderen stunden werden
aber momentan mit diese drei posten
zusammen
das erste muster ist sein dass der trend
ist vor dem hintergrund einer
chaotischen informations worden
dieses so zusammen nicht mehr kann man
die sie ihren besten der zeitung ein
museum soll herausgestellt werden was am
schulfest angeboten werden dieses für
jeden einzelnen
aufgabe geworden sie selbst eine ordnung
aus dieser chaotischen umgebung zu
generieren und die gründe operation mit
der das geschieht ist aus der auswahl
der auswahl an einer vielzahl von
möglichen dingen ist immer ein hinweis
darauf etwas ist wichtig
das kann im positiven und dem negativen
sind wichtig sein aber ist auch keine
aufmerksamkeit geben im moment kraft
dieses bild und entsprechend licht auf
die 100.000 millionen kinder und dich
auch hätte man es sagen auswählen können
diese auswahl die ist wächst immer noch
die kasse bedienen wobei man sehen muss
dass diese effektivität da komm ich
nachher noch genauer auch nicht mehr
jedes gebiet
sie erinnern sich an das bild des unions
dass er es auch dass das individuum
keine wissenschaft
naturwissenschaftliche kategorie werden
ist es häufen sich hinkel und studien
dazu dass eben auch das was wir als
individuen ersten komposite sind ein
symbiotisches konto sind und dass es im
grunde das was referenz sanität
kulturellen zeichnet ist ein dass
einzelne dinge zusammen gefügt werk
ausgewählt und zusammengefügt werden in
einer art und weise dass sie als
einzelne kinder sind aber gleichzeitig
ergeben das werde ich als einfach nur
tradition dass die summe aller teile und
ihnen diese arbeitete referenz rtl ist
eben das zusammen das auswählen und das
zusammenfügen ist bedeutendes
zuschreibung in bedeutung des generation
und wenn ihr uns die sozialen medien
anschauen sind die eigentliche macht
genau auszumachen
sie erlauben uns etwas zu denken dass
jetzt auch noch etwas zu scheren sehr
darunter
mit tieren aber jetzt einzustellen
aber im wesentlichen sind das sehr sehr
komplexe bilder in der nicht in der aus
der vielzahl von möglichkeiten eine
bestimmte serie von erfolgen in meiner
wahrnehmung trend aus dieser rechte
seite das ja nicht nur einmalig macht
dass sie nicht nur ein einziges mal
wieder soweit und das warten sondern ist
etwas das wir daran gemacht das ist eine
grund tätigkeit haben wenn er bedauernd
beschäftigt sind und wenn wir die
datenspuren hinterlassen
die anzeigen die im schlaf
neben den wenigen zu unterhalten damit
kommen wir hat hunderte wenn nicht
tausende zur referenz jener momente oder
handlungen redet und aus dieser summe
dieser dauernden ausbau muss es auch ein
film entsteht so etwas wie eine
sichtbarkeit der welt die welt liest
übernehmen und wie sie zunehmend auf
personalisierung ist euch noch darauf
mehr aus präsentiert wird die referenz
äth macht einer seite der wende
konstitution also wie nehme ich die
weltraum aus existieren vermissen was
existieren mich nicht aber um
gleichzeitig geben ist sie auch eine
selbst konzeption weil diese nicht in
sozialen abgeschlossenen privaten raum
stattfindet das ist nicht die sache
ruhig mit
und die mitte sondern dass er jeden was
mir wichtig ist also andere serie noch
nicht auswärts ausbauen
das allein ist und die schäden sichtbar
für andere und sei es nur die kerzen
bilder die ich auf facebook auswählen
damit konzentriere ich mich als person
niemals werden wir dort einen prozess
durch diese speziellen verfahren sie
einerseits die welt in balance und
konzentrieren und nicht der extrem in
der haben könnte ich aufhören das zu tun
die anderen
das ist ganz sicher ein wenig dass er
nicht zu hause
im abgeschlossenen raum eine sammlung
sondern die online die monieren eine
auswahl
sie leiten das bild das sich gebrüstet
haben die folge mehr auf winter und
damit sagen sie ja die auswertung
gemacht dies relevant
dies richtet was du siehst in der welt
ist ein wesentlicher elemente und somit
stabilisiert sich eine ausbauen und sich
dabei gleichzeitig ein paar ideen ja
nicht nur von außen wahrgenommen werden
und unsere selbst nachbauen
das heißt ich sehe was andere ausblenden
und darauf basiert das auch sagen dass
er weiter um eine konstruktion ebenfalls
im verhältnis oder meine eltern ihm
weiche das programm
es ist diese gemeinschaftlichkeit in der
diese selbst konzeption und konstruktion
stattfindet die das eigentlich für die
vitalität darstellt das ist sehr sehr
die coral veränderungen zum libero auf
zwei rechnen
das modell denn sie in der defense
konstruktion im privaten rahmen bzw
mentalen im namen stattfindet
jedenfalls die daumen
deshalb sind wir allein in der wolga und
deshalb schreibt wir den testenden
ländern ein
aber die komplexität der welt der
internationalen welt lässt sich nicht
mehr nur mit kognitiven fähigkeiten des
einzelnen oder gemeinschaften immer mehr
schneiden oder gründen komischer auswahl
und entscheidungsverfahren an der welt
wahrnehmung und dem ordnungsamt will
google und facebook zeigen uns nicht die
welt wie sie ist sondern sie machen die
welt für uns us börsen nun auch das
beispiel zu nennen zeigen und sich
einfach die flugpreise haben die es gibt
sondern sie versuchen einen möglichst
und die warnung reichen uns zu
generieren
leider tun sie das erste heimsieg
möglichst hohen preis zu generieren
deshalb suchen sie die oft teurer werden
sie das pc ausmachen ein verwenden kann
annehmen dass die biografie der der
magnum zahlungs und sage ihr eigentlich
irgend aber das ist auch vollkommen
anders wie wenn sie in der zeitung über
15 uhr zunächst die zeitung mit all den
schwierigkeiten die wendung ist aber
auch den anspruch den der sie nicht
immer gerecht
die welt uns eigentlich nicht welche
machen werde und facebook und nach die
anderen plattformen den anstecker und
für uns noch auf dieses bezogen zu
machen versuchen zu sagen was heißt so
eine perspektive für meldungen zu
skizzieren
ich werde mich jetzt sehr dünnes leisten
es ist nicht einfach wie es vielleicht
das ein oder andere weise das
weiterdenken
wenn die realität aus der sendung grund
überhaupt geworden ist genauso produkt
selbst machen mal ist ausmessen zu
gefährden
aber sie war ende oktober wurde dann
heißt das aber auch dass kleinen dingen
für sich selbst alleine steht sondern
bekommt an bedeutung immer erst über
verknüpfungen der welt auserwählt wird
ausgewählt mit aus gemeindevertretern
zusammenhang stehen
und jene art der dokumente ist man eine
von vielen verschiedenen möglichkeiten
denken sich das bestehende haus die gibt
es nur eine ordnung
alles ist immer mehr geworden
wenn ich hier natürlich ausverkauft
alles in allem in verbindung gebracht
werden kann
das note genau die baunachfrage in
ordnung aber das heißt auch dass es
nicht meine art der verbindung von dem
sondern ende viele und welche
verknüpfungen möglich ist welche
insgesamt menschen eine wortes
da steckt immer im verhältnis zur person
oder immer größer
daher stellen in den
kulturwissenschaften nennt sie so etwas
position a liad und die feministische
wissenschaft nennt so etwas zitiert das
ist das heißt dass es diese position von
außen die dass unbeteiligte seien über
beobachter nicht mehr jede aussage jede
verknüpfung ist immer auch ein aussagen
über die personen die diese verknüpfung
macht man kann nicht einen radikalen der
nationalismus nennen was aber nicht mehr
abgeraten und relativismus umzugehen
wissen
die betonung der sind wir seit es ist
uns stellt nicht das faktische in frage
es genießt recken außen glänzt aus
mitteln darüber geredet haben sondern es
streicht das partielle jeder absage
erfuhr was es nicht gibt der rolle
erfassen kann sondern aus dem
verschiedene blinkt reisen die teile
einer realität erfassen können
das heißt es jedes bieten
aber diese aus
unterschiedlichen partiellen positionen
sichtweisen in kontexte entstehen muss
entsprechend wenn es nicht mehr eine
position dient dass er das richtige
verhalten schienen werden könnte
dann muss es darum gehen in verschiedene
positionen miteinander zu verknüpfen und
das hier auf unterschiedlichkeit einen
produktiven mehr werden zu binden
lernen wird hier weniger zu wissen es
gewährt sondern hört aussagen von
bedeutung und man spricht hier etwas
verwirrend konzentriert werden sich
selbst wenn das wissen sein als eine
daumenbreite strengen wir nämlich sofort
benutzen
aber der wirkliche wille ist lernen
findet im austausch mit anderen in einer
gemeinschaft stand mindestes staat
horizontale einem endgerät nicht geben
die eine richtige position sozusagen
überall
sondern verschiedene legitime positionen
miteinander in verbindung setzen und
diese gemeinschaft die braucht einen
gewissen grad und diversität auf mich zu
hoch seien
so finden viele gemeinschaften gemeinsam
mit reifen aber das hat nicht zum
niedrig sein was können diese
unterschiedlichkeiten die komplexität
die aus dieser unterschiedlichkeit in
verschiedenen linken kommen nicht heraus
diesen gewissen grad
die große herausforderung die größte
herausforderung und sagen ist sicher die
die algorithmen zieht also das dauernde
mitschneiden von maschinen an
unternehmen in der berlin hier geht es
nicht mehr um eine klassische wenig
kompetenzen sinne des kritischen medien
und bleibt wichtig übertragen und wir
lernten sie konkret nicht es geht auch
nicht um anwender wissen sollten
benutzen
oder jene programm das ist auch nützlich
aber geht es auch an dem vorbei sondern
es geht darum die logik zu sagen das
gucken dass die menge des algorithmus zu
verstehen in der diskussion wenn das oft
computational thinking genommen das
kommt echt und denken geht es um ein
verständnis dessen möglichkeiten des
computers das aus dem moskau
sozusagen um den computer leisten und
muss danach nicht leisten was kommen
haben wir immer gewinnen das ist einfach
toll was die schwierig das ist
geschieden sinnvolle option da muss aber
nicht sein
es ist nicht das kommt hier und das ist
wichtiger wie die ankündigung ich möchte
damit es nicht so extrem aus braucht
bleibt
kleinen konkreten projekt in ihrer sicht
competitions denke dass ich sehr gut
kenne
der wind ist nicht meine ist nicht das
einzige das beste ist ist das heißt die
kunden und das projekt genau dass es
mittels genommen blog dass ihre sprache
erkennen dass gleichen das oft erst
erlaubt ein muster zu generieren welches
dann an der stickmaschine übergeben
werden kann und dort text heraus
gearbeitet und es geht auch um zu
verstehen welche art von muss dann
einfach generiert
der ex-meister sakko aus der kasse
gefordert wird auch nicht einfach in
einer einzelnen orte zu generieren und
oder dingen einfach erscheinen
sie sehe sehr strenge nichts umgestellt
reisen schwierig den kontext oktan
es geht hier um so die logik des
turniers des programms mit der logik des
sexuellen finden was zu melden
und der lobby sozusagen das motto das
lässt sich aus arbeiten unbedingt warum
bricht die nato rats für die gleichen
die gleiche stelle gehend mit einer 100
zu übersetzen und arbeit stellt nicht
die noten des programms sind bisher
sondern je nach interessen kann man so
sagen in diesen namen zu wählen gehen
oder immer der philologen das textil und
meide dem incorrect in designs
freizubekommen bestehenden des 1
ausgehen und experimentieren was
passiert immer nur gewisse variablen
verhindern
oder man kann elemente von bestehenden
designs zusammen
wir wählen aus weil wir finden die eine
der größten herausforderungen der
stabilität zu überlegen was das führung
zur verfügung sondern nur für unsere
gesellschaft unser bildungssystem
bedeutet ist das jahr der transformation
der strukturen der wahrnehmung selbst
konzentration mit des handelns zu
stellen
das geht weit über die in
anwenderspezifischen technologien hinaus
und sollte im zentrum der überlegungen
und neun bildungskonten stehen und nicht
die anschaffung von hardware
kessenich hingerichtet
es bleiben fragen
[Musik]
bis 8
frage kann ich jetzt auch nicht so dass
ich nicht sagen aber ich bin sozusagen
versuchen das ein bisschen rein darauf
setzen viele petit sierung nur zu sagen
wie viel prozent der erwachsenen können
sie in der offen lesen entscheiden
aber zu sehen dass das nur möglich ist
oder wir singen vorlesen erkaufen uns
fehlt von institutionen und mit der
bautrupp
sozusagen sozialen großen unternehmen
aus staufen nehmen sie diese fähigkeit
im centro nicht weniger automatisierung
schwieriger zum nächsten tagen abgeben
der pflicht internet kann ich gegen die
antwort nur so beantworten dass ich auch
nicht weiß welche verbände müssen
die
[Musik]
das g1 ist
zunächst will ich nur diese diese
trennung ein bisschen nach hinten
stellen kann mich ist sozusagen das aus
dem tal medien machen es was wir unseren
raum und welt - anders organisieren
planen und organisieren und die jeden
feststellung von oasis vorteil dass ich
namen und ähnlichen dingen
die software habe zeichen dass aus dem
volke organisation der welt über diese
themen die sie aufrufen
also für mich jetzt vor das heißt dass
das lässt sich nur um gegenüber einfluss
der fürst wir brauchen eine regelung
welche um namen zusammen fest werden
dürfen und welche nicht verlassen
hinter in den anderen bereichen zu
dürfen gewisse diese brauche ich nicht
auf meinem vorstellungsgespräch der
stadt auch so nicht sein
diese kriterium sein nachdem
herausbilden und sollte ähnliche
regelungen müssen wir finden für
automatisierten auswahlverfahren und
ausmessen ähnliche sämtliche etlichen
diskussionen die den namen
zwischen feldern führen dass es gar
nicht so sehr eine diskussion sondern
eine frage für welche vornamen welche
werden welche zielrichtungen wollen wir
wollen aus zusammengebaut werden und
welche nicht
kommunalen gestalteten vortrag unsere
welten größer